hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde eure intelligenzbestie
schlechthin meldet sich mal wieder hier
zurück aus der kommandozentrale der
dummheit mit einem neuen video von
reynaud dem spiel was ich überhaupt
nicht kann verstehe ich einfach das hier
ist das erste rätsel des heutigen videos
mama ist wieder da hilf mir das gamepad
zu verstecken also die mutter kommt und
wir müssen das game
ich kann nichts anklicken kann ich etwas
suchen das geht auch nicht ich habe
jetzt schon keinen plan mehr wenn ich
das handy irgendwie kippe oder so
passiert auch nichts
ich kann das auch nicht ziehen nicht
kleiner ziehen dann stellt darauf herum
drücken nehmen wir mal wieder da kann
ich ihnen was anderes anklicken
[Musik]
ich bin verzweifelt ich brauche decke
das gamepad für eine weile mit deinen
fingern sammer wollt ihr mich verarschen
stelle diese pyramide in drei schritten
auf den kopf kann aber ich kann was ich
kann
mit den hier
hey also sollen diese pyramide in drei
schritten auf den kopf stellen ich kann
hier allerdings nicht so richtig
irgendwie verschieben
daher so das ist doch so auf den kopf
schütteln geht auch nicht irgendwas
konsum geht auch nicht ich brauche einen
tipp bewege zwei kreise von der vierten
reihe zu
ich habe das so wenn ich das so mache es
[Musik]
mich regt diese app geisteskrank auf
schaltet jetzt bisher ab tippe in
reihenfolge 33 16 82 20 17 60 33 also
wir fangen aber der 33 da drückt ich
muss doch okay ich habe jetzt einfach
mal in der frage
wir sollen uns das merken also 33 16 8
220 jetzt habe ich schon keinen plan
mehr ich glaube es war 17 16
es war doch 17 60 hier oben 33 16 82 20
17 60
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachdem es falsch war was hilft dem
kleinen mädchen den kuchen zu essen als
wir können das kleine mädchen so bewegen
dann fällt sie hier runter jetzt also da
kommt sie nicht lange ich den kuchen
neben mädchen irgendwie den kuchen so
kann ich vielleicht falsch ich krieg das
video an
ja ich weiß ich bin jetzt auch nicht so
schlau also wir haben zwei glühbirnen
bekommen
ich werde es allerdings nicht direkt
einlösen sondern erst mal ausprobieren
ob es nicht irgendwie anders hinkriegen
wenn ich kann nicht vielleicht den
massen gedrückt halten und den
massenmedien kann ich nicht steuern wenn
ich mit dem mädchen nach rechts gehe so
komme ich hier auch nicht lange
das heißt wenn ich wieder nach rechts
gehe es falsch also ich muss irgendetwas
machen so dass das mädchen neben den
kuchen bekommt es ist auch einfach gar
kein kuchen das ist ein muffin bewege
ein brett und springe dann lief ich kann
das ist jetzt nicht da
ich kann jetzt
[Musik]
diese ganzen rätsel sind so einfach wenn
man dann mal die lösung hat
ja das stimmt auch als sie sechs jahre
alt war war lulu doppelt so alt wie sie
also 12 sowie ist jetzt zehn jahre alt
wie alt ist lulu also luo war doppelt so
alt also 12 also sechs jahre älter das
heißt in lulu ist jetzt 16
[Musik]
mitdenken kann nicht die regel aber wenn
schon mit den kuchen machen geht dann
geht es an meine grenzen danke für die
ausbildung ist aber nicht schlimm denn
wir machen jetzt wieder weiter auch
wieder mit der st
du musst dieses spiel erneut gewinnen
das hatten wir schon mal in einem
letzten video von brain aus einem jetzt
bist du dran okay also ich würde erstmal
hier ein
ich kann das spiel nicht gewinnen wollen
die so oder da ich kann ich beides
drücken geht auch nicht wie soll ich
dieses spiel gewinnen das ist falsch das
ist falsch
direkt auch wieder falschen bart war
moment so albert einstein er war die
wettfreunde er war nie weg wie isst man
die nudeln also ich würde erstmal wasser
in die macht doch safe woher gut dass du
dinge sind noch keine nudeln sind drin
wasser ist auch drin
das war da irgendwie so warum
muss sich denn die nudeln dann verziehen
damit man die kurze aber wer wäre
entwickelt diese app hilft dem baby
einzuschlafen ist rätsel nummer 95 sind
wir mittlerweile schon
wir versuchen aber das geht natürlich
nicht schneller geht natürlich auch
nicht um ball geht auch nicht also wie
gedrückt halten
bibi streicheln das hat natürlich auch
schon mal sowas mit streicheln war schon
schütteln bisschen von wegen soja ich
wiegt es in den stern mit baby oder
clique nation mal draufhalten sie ihr
gerät oben und unten und schaukeln sie
sich war
es geht nicht
es gebe ich jetzt einfach länger machen
müssen
das ist einfach nur noch dumm dieses
spiel wenn cde gleich edf dfh gleich chf
[Musik]
ich hab' ich bin experte ich hab' ich
hab den preis verdient ich schwöre euch
freude diese ganzen rätsel wo man
wirklich was in der birne für haben muss
und schnell kombinieren muss keine
ahnung was das kriechen abermals hier
findet den panda das sind alles anders
also ich klicke jetzt wirklich einfach
mal alles mögliche hier an so hier und
da einfach mal ein bisschen drauf um
vielleicht hin bei denen er dann einfach
die frage ist allerdings finde den panda
ich meine es sind ja alles brenders oder
sondern das ach so das ändert jetzt
natürlich die situation komplett ich
weiß allerdings nicht in welche richtung
[Musik]
hilft der kleinen fledermaus
einzuschlafen mit mahamat
die ganze sache ist immer falsch vor
allem ein kleiner hamster freuen wenn
das im panda als luca die sache ist dass
eine fledermaus ja eigentlich immer
etwas dran hängt schläft ja nicht im
sinne von sie stellt sich irgendwo auf
einem ast von daher würde ich sagen dreh
dich um ich um
die umbringen ich gebe bald business
kurse an universitäten freunde gibt die
größtmögliche zahl ein okay die größere
ich muss sagen hey ich kann nicht einen
tipp ich kann nicht ich ja auch so ich
muss auch die zahlen darauf dem ok das
jetzt natürlich verhalten weil ich denke
erst mal auf ok
nehmen wir die neuen die acht die 73 die
20 dienen null das ist natürlich
selbstverständlich falsch ist ja
breakout natürlich macht die sinnvollste
lösung kein wind kann ich dir 99 noch
kann ich sowieso
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum mache ich das hätte ihm
nachgefragt zeit zum schlafen gehen
bitte hilf mir das licht auszuschalten
als wir haben eine lampe natürlich wenn
ich an blick geht es nicht wir haben
allerdings zwei kabel und damit muss man
wahrscheinlich etwas machen ich weiß
allerdings noch nicht genau was das
gedrückthalten blaue kabel gelegt halten
auch nicht die beiden kabel
zusammenziehen das geht auch nicht
auseinander bewegen
frustrierend
so will ich diese verdammte app kette
muss jetzt wieder irgendwie schütteln da
geht es ihnen
[Applaus]
das ist jetzt nicht euer ernst kommen
wir nun allerdings auch schon zum
letzten rätsel fürs heutige video und
zwar welches ist das billigste wir haben
einen neuen dollar über china einen 10
dollar regenschirm bzw
so einen komischen traumfänger oder was
auch immer ist eine 5 dollar cola und 1
4 dollar gamepad ich wollte schon wieder
sagen das gamepad ist es natürlich nicht
das wäre auch zu doof aber dann war es
das gamepad
und das was auf das heutige video meine
lieben freunde was eine bescheuerte
überleitung denn euch bringt mit luca
einstellen die allerdings gefallen hat
meine lieben freunde dann lasst gern
einen daumen hoch oder ein video das
schaffen wir 30.000 likes auf jeden fall
mega krass und wird mit zeigen hey
machen
daumen hoch allerdings befinden wir uns
jetzt auch schon im auto meine lieben
freunde rom ist ein smiley eingebildet
dennoch kein teil der news seite also
meinen kanal noch nicht abonniert habt
dann klickt dort gern drauf das ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
und hier ist ein video verlinkt das
gestern auf meinem 2 kanal online
gegangen ist in dem wir uns kontroverse
aktionen von deutschen youtube
angeschaut haben